let's bring in Todd McShea ESPN NFL
draft analyst come on in Todd how are
you you're all worked up this morning
huh well you know being from Cincinnati
people think that oh you know you kick
us when we're down I'm just analyzing
this situation and let's say you're Joe
burrows agent what would you tell your
client right now what would you consider
Oh personally I would tell him just to
get drafted where you drafted and go
play okay but I I could understand if if
you looked at the big picture and tried
to try to force something else I don't
think it's gonna happen though
I really don't especially with Joe being
from the state of Ohio I think I think I
mean think about a year ago I had him as
a fourth fifth round pick and he was
transferring to LSU and he felt
fortunate to just get from Ohio State to
LSU but he was except on the depth chart
at Ohio State and now to have the
opportunity to be the first overall pick
and to be a player that's going to wind
up getting guaranteed 33 34 million
dollars over the next five years it kind
of doesn't matter where you go
and if especially if you're going to be
in the state that you grew up in I think
he should take some pride in that and
and go and try to be the guy that turns
around the Bengals and brings them to
you know back to the playoffs and it has
success with them but who knows what's
gonna happen and I'm all for that though
Todd I hope he I hope he honors that and
goes number one and goes to Cincinnati I
mean I like that I admire that if you
want to go when you want to start
something you want to create something
you would have build something on all
four that it's just I I don't know what
his mindset is I don't know what you
know the people behind him are the only
Steinberg are going yeah of course he
gonna go there I don't know what they're
thinking I'm just I'm wondering is there
a team that would want to go up and get
Joe borough
is there a team with the draft capital
that would say we're gonna can would
Miami go up and get Miami's interesting
because they've got three picks in the
first round obviously so they have the
capital to do it but if you're the if
you're the Bengals why do you make that
deal and I thought about this last night
because I mean everyone knows that they
try to save money right they try to run
it as a business and make money off of
this organization yeah and and
apparently making money is just as
important if not more important than
winning so if you have a quarterback
that you can pay thirty three thirty
four million dollars over the next five
years versus you know some guys are
making thirty million close to a year
you know so I don't know why you just
don't stay at home at number one and
take Joe Burrell and and see where it
goes from there and hope hopefully you
can bring you a lot of success why move
back and then and play around with it
and wind up with three first-round picks
or two first-round picks in the second
round pick whatever the deal would be
and and still not have your quarterback
so i if i'm the bengals the only thing
to me that makes sense is to draft Joe
borough and you know when teams talk
about well they got a lot of draft picks
I want to know who's making the picks
there there's only one Ozzie Newsome
here and you can have these draft picks
like the Cleveland Browns boy they got
all these draft picks and then they
didn't do well with those draft picks
that's where I would get nervous even
with Miami you know they it feels like
they may have something there with their
coat head coach Brian floors and they
played hard for him they got rid of
their big stick you know
big ticket items there now what are you
going to do with the draft you know so
why I understand you know sort of this
scenario with a lot of these teams but
just because you got great you know a
lot of draft picks doesn't mean you're
gonna have a great football crew but I
do think my aim is tough because because
of the market but but i but fours is a
really good coach and and Chris Grier is
a really good evaluator and so I think
they have the
people in place to try to put it
together you're picking it five and
maybe you get to a tongue of Eylau it
that that spot of heat medically checks
out and then you've got two more picks
let you know later in the first round
this is an opportunity as an
organization to turn things around and
the readers are there in the same same
place and well they'd rather have the
Bengals future or the Dolphins future I
would rather have the Dolphins future
okay yeah because of the people the
people making the decisions and knowing
that the people in Miami want to win and
they they want to spend money and they
want to do the right things and you've
got three first-round picks we're
talking to Todd McClay his latest mock
draft 2.0 now available on ESPN plus if
tool was healthy I would be a great
debate it would be a great debate Dan I
mean it really would be I I personally
would take to over Joe if if there was
no medical concerns that they were both
clean medically I really would I mean he
he is he's drew brees from the left side
that's what he is and who wouldn't take
drew brees number one over here you know
he's just but what I'm concerned about
is and what everyone in the league is
concerned about I spent a week at the
Senior Bowl talking to TMS and and head
coaches and and you know Scouts and
everyone else and medical people the
concern is and nobody knows you can
anyone who tells you that they know what
the answer is right now is lie nobody
knows how he's going to recover because
he's young enough to recover but this is
an injury that it could take a while and
it could also six seven years down the
road it could be degenerative so is he
going to be the same quick twitch
athlete that he was at Alabama when he
was playing at the highest level and
he's is he able going to be to be
healthy and available
you know availability we always talked
about that
it's it's the most important ability but
if he does get back to that you're
talking about one of the best
quarterback prospects we've seen in the
last five six years coming out of the
draft in terms of accuracy efficiency
and in today's game
just quickly processing knowing where to
go with the football and being able to
move around and create passing windows I
Drew Brees is the perfect top for him
but is he going to get back to that
because the hip is just such a big big
concern I'll leave you with this
question
the team between Detroit and New York
that may move down to allow somebody to
go up and get to it because it feels
like it's been Miami that was going to
get to I and nobody of course is gonna
play their cards and show you their
cards but is somebody moving up to get
somebody well I don't so I think since
he's gonna sit sit sit at home I think I
should and just take your borough
take it to the Redskins are just going
to take chase young and that's exactly
what they should do yeah he's the best
player in this year's draft then Detroit
would be the team to me if if there was
interest from let's say the Dolphins at
five the Chargers at six
the Panthers at seven even going all the
way down to I don't know the Colts at 13
the Buccaneers at 14 it I think if
you're the Lions you're it and you're
not looking to drop the quarterback and
I don't think that they need to at this
point I think that number three spot is
the most interesting because you can get
ahead of the Dolphins and you can go
basically line yourself up to get to if
the medical report is right and that's a
guy you believe in and the other thing
is I don't I'm not a huge Justin Herbert
fan but I've talked to enough general
managers and head coaches in the league
that really liked the Oregon quarterback
because of his size and his ability to
be developed and his intelligence and
everything that he brings to the table
there were some teams that that really
liked him and I think I said do you know
how it goes all three of these guys are
going to be off the board in the top ten
when it's all said and done a lot of
time before then though that's the fun
part of all of this you got a few more
mock drafts don't you yeah kuiper keeps
adding I think we're gonna have like 9.0
at some point he they were doing mock
draft every single day drives me nuts I
love them but I don't you guys should
put money in a pool like like like
$5,000 okay and most wins like $5,000
for charity most correct picks in the
first time so make it interesting where
there's something attached to it that's
a great idea
we're gonna do that here you go we're
scoot Stewart's I get the I get redeye
all right we'll pick our own charities
yeah and that's what we're gonna do done
okay that's the best idea I've heard all
week there you go I thought all I do is
give thank you thank you Tom that's Todd
McShea for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]